This matrix is a translation matrix. Because only this fourth column is
different than the identity matrix. These values are the translation amounts.
This matrix is a rotation matrix. Because the upper left three by three has been
modified, and not in a simple way like a scaling matrix. I should mention that
if the three by three areas change in a arbitrary way you can get what is called
a sheer matrix. I see sheer matrices get mentioned in textbooks, hey, we cover
them in our own book. But personally in the past three decades I've never used a
sheer matrix. This matrix has elements of both translation and rotation and so
is the two of these types multiplied together. This leaves the last matrix as a
scaling matrix, it's a non-uniform scaling along each axis.